bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va reparler du stock
simon ma première vidéo sur le
me a été sans doute l'une des plus
importantes de ma chaîne et l'intérêt
que vous avez manifesté pour cette vidéo
m'a fait comprendre que vous ne seriez
pas opposé à l'idée d'un deuxième
épisode
même si cette première vidéo était assez
complète au sens où j défini les bases
de la philosophie stoïcienne je me dis
que ça pourrait être pas mal de
compléter cette première vidéo par une
deuxième dans laquelle je vais vous
proposer une autre approche
mais avant ça un petit rappel historique
sur le stoïcisme donc le stoïcisme c'est
un mouvement de la philosophie grecque
du 3e siècle avant jésus-christ le
stoïcisme a été fondée par et non de
kitsch on à ne pas confondre avec zénon
d'elée le sophiste et la première chose
très importante qu'on doit retenir à
propos du stoïcisme c'est qu'il s'agit
d'une philosophie total une philosophie
total c'est à dire à la fois une
philosophie théorique et une philosophie
pratique si vous préférez le stoïcisme
ne consiste pas simplement dans un
système d'explication et de
compréhension du monde
il existe des philosophies qui vont pour
objectif principal de comprendre le
monde
mais avec le stoïcisme on va un peu plus
loin parce que le but ultime
ce n'est pas seulement de comprendre
c'est aussi d'agir le stoïcisme
c'est une philosophie de l'action et une
philosophie de l'action ça porte un nom
ça s'appelle l'éthique le stoïcisme est
une éthique éthique ça vient du grec et
os qui signifie précisément comportement
et c'est l'idée qu'on retrouve dans le
mot éthologie qui est l'étude des
comportements animaux donc les tos c'est
un comportement c'est une conduite c'est
une manière d'être et le stoïcisme va
nous éclairer va nous renseigner sur la
meilleure conduite à adopter dans notre
vie il va nous dire pour le résumer
simplement comment agir pour être
heureux le bonheur a toujours
constitué l'aspiration ultime de la
philosophie on trouvait déjà cette idée
chez socrate plus chez platon à savoir
que la philosophie doit nous guider vers
le bonheur et le bonheur s'identifie
avec la sagesse atteindre le bonheur
c'est atteindre la sagesse et vous direz
quel rapport entre le bonheur et la
sagesse il ya c'est très simple le sage
c'est celui qui parce qu'il a compris le
monde parce qu'il a compris l'ordre des
choses n'en ai plus affectées affecté au
sens émotionnel
le sage c'est celui qui n'est plus
troublé dont l'amener plus tourmentés et
pour les anciens
c'était ça le bonheur le fait de ne plus
être tourmenté le fait de trouver
l'équilibré
l'alignement ce qu'on appellera la paix
intérieure
alors avant d'aller plus loin on va
faire une petite distinction importante
entre la morale et l'éthique
je vous ai dit que le stoïcisme c'était
une éthique et je distinguerai bien ici
l'éthique de la morale
pourquoi parce que la morale c'est un
ensemble de règles de comportement qui
repose sur la séparation entre le bien
et le mal et on en a parlé dans la
dernière vidéo sur nietzsche parler de
bien et de mal c'est sous-entendre que
le bien et le mal sont des absolus des
absolus qui ne se discute pas des
absolus transcendant et d absolu qui
réclament de notre part une obéissance
aveugle
la morale c'est ce à quoi on obéit sans
se poser de questions et d'ailleurs on
en trouve l'illustration dans
l'éducation qu'on peut donner à nos
enfants
quand un enfant fait une bêtise quand il
enfreint une règle morale là
généralement on va le sanctionner
on va le punir autrement dit la morale
repose sur la notion d'impératifs la
morale ça ne se discute pas ça ne se
négocie pas ça représente une autorité à
laquelle on n'a pas le droit de désobéir
c'est vraiment ça qui est contenu dans
l'idée de morale l'idée d'un
commandement la morale nous commande et
d'ailleurs on trouve une assez bonne
illustration de ces règles morales dans
la religion dans la religion il nous est
dit que si on enfreint les règles
morales les règles morales est dit
tu es par dieu on sera puni on sera
envoyé en enfer
on sera jugé par le tout puissant et ce
jugement sera la marque du caractère
absolu des règles morales le fait que
nous n'avons pas notre mot à dire sur
les règles morales la formule qui résume
vrai le mieux l'esprit de la morale
s'est agi ainsi et d'ailleurs ça nous
rappelle immédiatement l'impératif
catégorique de kant qui commence de
cette manière agis de telle sorte que
donc dans la morale il y à l'idée que
nous n'avons pas le choix nous devons
obéir
nous devons nous soumettre aux
impératifs moraux et si nous nous en
carton nous serons puis nous seront
sanctionnés sans possibilité de corriger
notre comportement sans possibilité
d'apprendre de nos erreurs
ça c'est pour la morale qu'en est il
maintenant de l'éthique bien l'éthique
c'est un petit peu différent c'est à
dire que là où la morale commandes
l'éthique recommande elle recommande
c'est à dire
elle nous avertit elle nous informe elle
nous informe de quoi eh bien nous
informe des conséquences d'un mauvais
comportement
les tic ne nous dit pas agi ainsi
l'éthique nous dit si tu agi ainsi voilà
ce qui va arriver si tu agi ainsi voilà
les conséquences
donc il n'ya pas d'impératifs dans les
tic
il ya simplement l'avertissement des
conséquences de nos actes il ya
simplement la prévention des effets de
notre conduite
donc si vous préférez les tic repose sur
la notion de responsabilité on est
responsables de nos actes au sens où on
doit en répondre
et en répondre c'est en assumer les
conséquences c'est de dire par exemple
tu veux voler la voiture de ton voisin
hockey fait le mais attends toi à ce que
ton voisin se venge attends toi à te
retrouver en garde à vue et à être
condamné par la justice et donc à ce
moment là l'individu a le choix
il a le choix de transgresser la règle
il a le choix d'aller à l'encontre de la
règle mais en faisant ce choix
il choisit en même temps les
conséquences de son choix et c'est ça la
responsabilité c'est connaître les
conséquences de nos choix et
conséquences de nos actes
et de choisir si on n'agit ainsi ou pas
mais une fois qu'on a fait cette
distinction entre la morale et l'éthique
on s'aperçoit malgré tout qu'il ya un
dénominateur commun le dénominateur
commun c'est que dans les deux cas on
présuppose qu'il existe un modèle de
bonne conduite
un modèle de bonne conduite ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi
ça veut dire qu'on est obligé de donner
un cadre à notre comportement on peut
pas faire tout et n'importe quoi parce
que la morale nous punira ou parce que
l'éthique nous aura prévenu que nous
devrons assumer les conséquences de
notre comportement
mais dans les deux cas il y à bien
l'idée que nous devons donner à notre
action
un cadre et des limites dans la morale
ce modèle de bonne conduite
c'est tout simplement l'idée du bien le
concept de bien avec toutes les
difficultés que cela implique du point
de vue de sa définition dans la religion
c'est dieu qui définit le modèle de la
bonne conduite
c'est par exemple les dix commandements
dans l'ancien testament c'est par
exemple la parole du christ dans les
évangiles ou encore les cinq piliers de
l'islam
mais dans les tic stoïcienne quel est le
modèle de la bonne conduite
quel est le modèle que nous devons
suivre dans notre comportement quotidien
la police le sien la réponse est très
simple le modèle à suivre dans notre
conduite
ce sont les lois universelles les lois
universelles c'est-à-dire l'ordre
naturel l'ordre cosmique et là on voit
bien que le modèle de comportement des
stoïciens n'est pas un modèle
transcendant au sens où il s'agirait
d'une autorité extérieure au monde ce
qui doit nous guider dans notre
comportement
ce sont les principes inhérents à notre
monde inhérents à l'univers ce qu'on
appellera la raison universelle parce
que pour les stoïciens il existe un
ordre naturel
il existe un ordre cosmique et septembre
cosmique ce n'est rien d'autre que
l'ensemble des principes et des lois qui
font que notre monde fonctionne qui font
que notre monde est viable et que tout
est à sa place dans l'univers
que se passerait-il si les planètes
décidé tout à coup de changer leur
trajectoire
autrement dit que se passerait-il si les
planètes désobéissait à l'ordre que
l'univers tel que nous le connaissons
n'existerait tout simplement pas le
moindre décalage le moindre écart
vis-à-vis des lois universelles
provoquerait tout simplement
l'effondrement du monde donc il existe
un ordre universel
il existe une harmonie cosmique et
d'ailleurs c'est presque un pléonasme
puisque cosmos en grec
ça signifiait ordre ordre ou harmonie
donc le mot même de cosmos présuppose
l'idée d'un ordre le monde n'existerait
pas s'il n'y avait pas un ordre du monde
et d'ailleurs ça peut paraître une idée
assez étrange à sa abstraite mais quand
on y réfléchit
que font les physiciens que font les
cosmologistes il étudie l'ordre de
l'univers
il étudie les lois de l'univers les lois
de l'univers en mouvement qui si elle
venait à être modifié ferait que notre
univers n'existerait plus parler de lois
physiques ses présupposés qu'il existe
derrière les phénomènes physiques
observable un principe qui les régit une
loi qui les guide et donc cette
expression même de lois physiques elle
dit bien ce qu'elle veut dire elle veut
dire que les phénomènes physiques ne
sont pas des phénomènes aléatoires ne
sont pas des phénomènes irrégulier qui
auraient la possibilité de se modifier à
chaque instant par les deux lois
physiques c'est parler d'une
métaphysique
c'est parler de quelque chose qui excède
le pur phénomène physique parce que la
loi physique elle n'est pas observable
la loi physique elle n'est pas elle-même
physique
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il y a dans l'idée même de lois
physiques
l'idée qu'il existe quelque chose
au-delà du physique ou en tout cas
quelque chose dans le physique qui
échappe au physique quelque chose dans
le physique qui n'est pas physique
c'est en se
scotché les stoïciens la physique et la
métaphysique ne font qu'un il n'y a pas
de distinction à faire entre le physique
et la métaphysique puisque la physique
est gorgée de métaphysique et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut facilement
comprendre à travers l'idée de loi de la
causalité la loi de la causalité
c'est ce qui fait qu'une cause va
produire un effet et c'est ce qui fait
que les mêmes causes produiront toujours
les mêmes effets alors évidemment c'est
très difficile dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation de reproduire
exactement les mêmes causes parce que
par définition de phénomène ne se
reproduise jamais à l'identique
ne serait ce que parce qu'ils ne se
produisent pas au même moment et donc
s'ils ne se produise pas au même moment
ils ne peuvent pas être identique mais
la loi de la causalité vous
l'expérimenté tous les jours vous
l'expérimenté même à chaque instant
c'est à dire que si vous tenez votre
verre d'eau et que vous le lâcher qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans le vert d'eau
va tomber par terre
il va se briser à vos pieds et vous
savez très bien
n'allez pas vous amuser à vérifier les
lois physiques en vous disant tient
peut-être que si je lâche mon verre
d'eau cette fois ci il va tomber vers le
haut peut-être qu'il va rester à flotter
dans les airs non vous savez bien que
non vous savez bien que non parce que
vous avez suffisamment expérimenté les
lois physiques et notamment la loi de la
gravitation pour savoir ce qu'il va
arriver si vous lâchez le vert et qu'il
va tomber la loi de la causalité
c'est donc l'idée que toute action va
entraîner un effet et que cet effet il
est directement dépendant de l'action
que vous aurez effectué il n'y a pas
d'indépendance entre la cause et son
effet il ya au contraire un lien
nécessité le lien nécessité c'est à dire
l'idée que ça ne peut pas se produire
autrement on peut pas y avoir d'autres
effets que celui qui est inclus dans la
cause
c'est ça le cas de nécessité c'est ça la
loi de la causalité c'est l'idée que
l'effet contient en lui la cause dont il
est issu on va prendre un autre exemple
qui n'est pas de nature physique et
simplement pour montrer que la loi de
causalité ne régit pas simplement les
phénomènes physiques
imaginez que vous vous baladez dans la
rue et vous allez voir un passant vous
vous interposé devant lui et vous lui
dites ils ont toi tu sais que tu es
vraiment moche
tu sais que tu as vraiment une tête d'
imbéciles on peut imaginer lui dire
autre chose
mais imaginez que vous lui dites quelque
chose d'offensant quelque chose de
gratuitement méchant là ce moment-là
qu'est ce qui va se passer
peut-être la personne va vous mettre un
coup de boule peut-être que la personne
va vous renvoyer vos insultes
ou peut-être que la personne va
continuer son chemin en se disant il ya
vraiment des cas sur terre dans tous les
cas votre action aura eu un effet un
effet qui est en correspondance directe
avec la cause c'est à dire que c'est
assez rare que la personne vous fasse un
grand sourire et vous prenne dans ses
bras
alors je ne dis pas que c'est impossible
et c'est quand même assez rare
et pourquoi c'est assez rare parce qu en
agissant de manière hostile vous aurait
produit une réaction à votre style it et
qui ne peut être par définition qu'une
contre hostilités
l'hostilité peut se traduire de
différentes manières elle peut se
traduire par des violences physiques
comme elle peut se traduire par une
indifférence méprisante
mais dans tous les cas une action
hostile va produire une réaction hostile
autrement dit le réel va répondre à ce
que vous lui aurait fait subir le réel
va répondre à votre action sur lui le
réel aura produit les faits dont vous
étiez la cause donc vous voyez que la
loi de la causalité n'est pas simplement
cantonné aux phénomènes physiques à
proprement parler et que dans les
interactions humaines dans nos choix de
vie les plus quotidiens il y à aussi de
la causalité
c'est simplement qu'il s'agit d'une
causalité multifactorielle et que donc
les réactions humaines ne sont pas aussi
mécanique que les réactions des objets
inanimés
il ya des paramètres psychologique il ya
des paramètres émotionnel il ya des
paramètres contextuel qui font que tout
le monde ne va pas réagir exactement de
la même manière aux mêmes causes mais ce
que nous disent les stoïciens c'est que
la loi de la causalité elle contrainte
où elle englobe tout on peut pas y
échapper
on ne peut pas
taku en faire abstraction comme si elles
n'existaient pas et parce que nous
possédons une raison parce que nous
possédons à discernement nous sommes
capables d'ajuster nos actions en
fonction de cette loi de la causalité
est donc ce que nous disent les
stoïciens c'est que la première étape
pour bien agir
la première étape pour adopter bonne
conduite et trouver le bonheur c'est
être conscient de cette loi de la
causalité qui contraint tous qui englobe
tout c'est être conscient que chacune de
nos actions a une conséquence une série
de conséquences puisque les conséquences
deviennent à leur tour des causes qui
vont produire d'autres effet la première
étape pour devenir un sage stoïcien
c'est donc de comprendre l'ordre du
monde
et si on arrive à comprendre l'ordre du
monde bien à ce moment là il va nous
devenir possible de vivre en accord avec
ses lois cosmiques va devenir capable de
vivre en conformité avec l'ordre naturel
et la sagesse pour les stoïciens c'est
un comportement juste pour l'exposition
c'est un comportement qui imite en même
temps qu'ils s'en inspirent l'ordre
naturel parce qu'en agissant
conformément à l'ordre naturel on
devient une partie de cet ordre naturel
on devient une fraction de l'ordre
cosmique
c'est à dire qu'en tant qu'individu en
tant que parties du monde
nous en sommes en même temps un fragment
et le fragment se doit d'être composée
aux mêmes proportions que ce dont ils et
fragments pour atteindre le bonheur
nous devons être un échantillon de
l'ordre cosmique ainsi pour les stations
pour bien agir il faut d'abord
comprendre le monde
il faut d'abord en passer par la
physique du monde et la physique du
monde va nous conduire à la métaphysique
du monde c'est à dire aux lois qui se
tiennent en amont des phénomènes
physiques et une fois qu'on a accédé à
cette métaphysique fois qu'on a accédé à
cet ordre cosmique
il devient possible d'imiter l'ordre
cosmique dans nos comportements et à ce
moment là qu'est ce qui se passe
eh bien il se passe que nous ne sommes
plus un corps étranger au monde
nous ne sommes plus une fourmi perdu
dans l'univers intergalactique qui
cherche sa fourmilière
nous devenons des incarnations sur terre
de l'ordre cosmique
voilà pourquoi il est possible de dire
que le stoïcisme est une philosophie
totale parce que le stoïcisme c'est à la
fois une physique une métaphysique et
une éthique qui en découle la physique
conduit à la métaphysique et la
métaphysique débouche sur le modèle
éthique et c'est ce qui fait que d'une
manière générale dans la philosophie
antique
tous les domaines sont indissociables
tous les domaines sont interdépendants
parce que dissocier la physique de la
métaphysique ou de l'éthique c'est ne
pas comprendre la loi de correspondance
qui nient tous ces domaines c'est ne pas
comprendre qu'il s'agit de la même chose
vu différemment
alors la prochaine question qui se pose
c'est comment agir conformément à cet
ordre naturel
comment être les incarnations de l'ordre
cosmique ce que nous disent les
stoïciens c'est que la nature nous
envoient des informations en permanence
et c'est ça qui définit le lien entre la
compréhension de la nature et la vertu
c'est à dire limitation de cet ordre
naturel
la nature nous envoie des signaux en
permanence et c'est à nous de les
prendre en compte
c'est à nous de les voir ces signaux et
de les utiliser comme moyen d'orienter
notre action parce que se passe-t-il si
on ne prend pas en compte ces signaux
que se passe-t-il si on n'écoute pas les
informations que nous envoie la nature
on va souffrir si on n'écoute pas les
signaux de la nature on va souffrir les
lois de la nature
c'est le guide de nos actions pour
éviter la souffrance la nature c'est le
manuel cryptée pour atteindre le bonheur
quand vous souffrez
il y a toujours une raison cette raison
peut ne pas vous apparaître de manière
évidente cette raison peut être une
raison enfouis mais il ya toujours une
raison la souffrance
ce n'est pas une réponse à rien c'est
une réponse à quelque chose parce que
tout est une réponse à quelque chose
parce que tout est une réaction à une
cause et donc ce que nous disent les
stoïciens c'est que quand nous souffrons
la première question que nous devons
nous poser c'est pourquoi souffrons d'où
vient ma souffrance quelle est la cause
dont ma souffrance est la conséquence
c'est ça qui me disent de faire les
stoïciens comprendre quelle est la cause
de notre souffrance et parce que le
monde est régi par la loi de la
causalité
autrement dit parce que tout est
rationnel parce que la raison contre 1
to il y as forcément une cause il y a
toujours une raison mais alors quelle
est cette raison qui fait que nous
souffrons y compris quand nous n'avons
pas l'impression d'avoir fait quelque
chose de mal et quand je dis quelque
chose de mal je veux dire par là quand
nous avons l'impression de ne pas avoir
initié d'action dont notre souffrance
serait la conséquence dont notre
souffrance serait la réponse
donc là on parle d'une souffrance
intérieure on parle pas forcément d'une
souffrance physique comme la gueule de
bois est une souffrance physique comme
le fait de tomber par terre alors qu'on
s'est jeté dans le vide est aussi une
souffrance physique parce que là c'est
facile de comprendre la cause de cette
souffrance
la cause de cette souffrance elle nous
est donnée directement par la
connaissance des lois physiques mais
lorsqu'on parle d'une souffrance
intérieure
lorsqu'on parle du tourments de l'âme
comment comprendre cette souffrance
comment la comprendre pour la supprimer
comme on la comprendre pour s'en libérer
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la réponse
célèbre des stoïciens qui est de dire
que ce qui tourmente notre âme c'est le
fait de désirer que les choses se
produisent
autrement que de la manière dont elles
se produisent ces deux désirs et que
l'ordre des choses ne soient pas ce
qu'il est mais ce que nous voudrions
qu'il soit pour prendre une analogie
c'est comme de désir et qu'ils fassent
35 degrés en plein hiver le problème ne
vient pas de l'hiver le prof
vient de notre désir le problème vient
de notre désir que l'ordre des choses
soit autrement que ceux qui menaient
donc ça c'est très facile à comprendre
dans la vie de tous les jours
par exemple s'il matin avant de sortir
vous apercevez qu'il pleut ben vous
allez prendre un parapluie
vous allez vous équiper en conséquence
vous n'allez pas vous dire ah non moi
aujourd'hui je veux qu'il fasse beau
donc je me mets en tee shirt et le temps
va changer pour moi
on savait que ça ça n'arrivera pas vous
n'avez pas le pouvoir de changer le
climat mais l'être humain pense qu'il a
le pouvoir ou en tout cas ils aimeraient
se persuader qu'il a le pouvoir de
changer l'ordre des choses autour de lui
il aime croire par exemple qui peut
avoir des résultats sans faire les
efforts pour les obtenir
prenons le cas de celui qui veut devenir
riche et pour qui le projet de devenir
riche
ça consiste tout simplement dans le
désir de devenir riche
mais si ce désir à un moment ou un autre
n'est pas le moteur d'une série
d'actions pour parvenir à ce résultat
cet homme-là ils se condamnent au
malheur ils se condamnent à la déception
à la frustration
il se condamne à ne jamais voir advenir
son désir dans la réalité est là encore
j'ai pris un exemple assez extrême mais
on est tous concernés par cette tendance
la tendance à vouloir des résultats sans
vouloir les causes parce que les causes
elles sont coûteuses
parce que les causes elle dépend de nos
efforts et qu'on n'aime pas faire des
efforts on aimerait que les conséquences
se produisent sans les causes et un
verre
seulement on aimerait parfois que les
causes n'entraîne pas de conséquences on
aimerait aller voir le passant est
l'insulté sans qu'il y ait de sa part
une réaction d'hostilité encore je
caricature mais l'idée c'est qu'on
voudrait que notre comportement n'est
pas de conséquences en tout cas n'ait
pas de conséquences fâcheuses pour nous
et pas de conséquences désagréables
on fonctionne souvent comme ça fait
quelque chose
on s'étonne des réactions à ce qu'on
fait on s'étonne de la réponse que le
réel apportent à ce qu'on fait par
exemple on décide de vivre de manière
totalement égoïste on refuse de partager
on refuse d'aider on refuse d'écouter et
le jour où on a besoin qu'on nous donne
qu'on nous aide ou qu'on nous écoute
il n'y a plus personne et là on se
plaint et l'enzyme et le monde est
injuste le monde est injuste avec moi le
monde m'a pris pour cible l'univers
conspire à me faire du mal
l'univers conspire à me faire souffrir
autrement dit on a une tendance à
prendre les choses personnellement ne
pas vouloir entendre qu'il y à des
mécanismes qui régissent la réalité est
que ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes
pris à l'intérieur de ces mécanismes que
ces mécanismes s'adresse à nous ce n'est
pas parce que la loi de la causalité se
montre parfois durs contre nous qu'on a
créé la loi de la causalité pour nous
faire du mal
john la causalité n'a pas été créé pour
nous faire du mal
elle a été créée pour nous faire
comprendre comment éviter la souffrance
il ya des cas où la souffrance est
injuste sens où elle n'est pas
conséquence directe de notre
comportement
ça ça existe et puis il ya des cas où
notre souffrance est aussi la résultante
de ce que nous avons fait celui qui se
comporte de manière égoïste toute sa vie
ne pourra pas se plaindre que la réponse
du réel à son égoïsme ce soit contre
l'égoïsme celui qui se
sa vie de manière violente ne pourra pas
se plaindre le jour où cette violence va
se retourner contre lui devra l'assumer
devra l'assumer comme la réponse du réel
à son comportement
oui c'est là qu'on retrouve la
distinction entre la morale et l'éthique
dont on parlait au début de cette vidéo
à savoir que la sanction ne réside pas
dans une autorité extérieure qui nous
dit c'est mal
la sanction réside dans une réponse
interne aux lois naturelles qui font que
chaque cause produit son effet dans tous
les cas le tourments de l'âme n'est pas
l'oeuvre d'un monde méchant et hostile
avec nous c'est l'oeuvre de notre
incapacité à comprendre pourquoi nous
souffrons le tourments de l'âme
c'est l'oeuvre de nous mêmes et c'est
d'autant plus l'oeuvre de nous mêmes que
nous sommes en capacité de modifier nos
états d'âme
états d'âme parce que nous sommes en
capacité de modifier la représentation
que nous avons des choses
nous avons la capacité de modifier notre
perception du monde
ce qui veut dire que si tout à coup au
lieu de recevoir la souffrance comme une
injustice que nous inflige le monde on
se pose simplement la question
que puis-je y faire la réponse des
stoïciens sera de dire accepte accepte
parce que tu n'as pas d'autre choix que
d'accepter
alors si tu as le choix de refuser mais
alors ce refus va être la source de ta
souffrance parce qu'en réalité ce qui
fait souffrir n'est pas ce qui t'arrive
ce qui fait souffrir c'est le refus que
cela t'arrive ce qui te fait souffrir
c'est une représentation de ce qui
t'arrive
nous ne souffrons pas à cause de ce que
nous vivons nous souffrons à cause de la
représentation de ce que nous vivons
nous souffrons à cause de l'idée que
l'on s'en fait et cette idée
elle va venir tourmenté notre âme elle
va venir générer des émotions
elle va venir générer du ressentiment
générer de l'inquiétude de la jalousie
de l'aigreur du regret elle va venir
brasse et nos émotions et en faire un
brasier à souffrance céline acceptation
de ce qui est qui nous fait souffrir et
non pas ce que nous
ce ne sont pas les événements qui sont
la cause de notre souffrance c'est notre
perception des événements
nous ne pouvons pas faire en sorte que
le monde se comporte comme on voudrait
qu'il se comporte soit pas en capacité
de modifier l'ordre cosmique mais nous
sommes en capacité de comprendre que
l'ordre cosmique ne peut pas être
autrement que ceux qui venaient nous
sommes en capacité de comprendre qu'il
ya des choses qui ne dépend pas de nous
qui ne dépend pas de notre désir qui ne
dépende même pas de notre action et dans
ces cas là le tournant de notre âme
ce n'est rien d'autre que le refus que
l'ordre du monde soit ce qu'il n'est le
tourments de l'âme c'est le refus
d'accepter que les choses soient ce
qu'elles sont c'est le refus de
comprendre la raison universelle
alors évidemment ce problème du
tourments de l'âme ce problème de la
souffrance intérieure
c'est d'abord un problème humain parce
que même si on peut trouver ce qui
s'apparenterait à des émotions dans le
règne animal
il est clair que les animaux sont
davantage dominé par leur instinct et
que d'une certaine manière les animaux
n'ont pas vraiment la possibilité de
contourner leur instinct c'est ce qui
fait que les animaux n'ont pas besoin
d'un manuel pour savoir comment se
comporter
parce que leurs manuels il est inscrit
dans leur code génétique
il est inscrit dans leur instinct nous
sommes des animaux nous possédons une
dimension animal c'est ce qui fait que
nous aussi nous avons un instant nous
avons un instinct de conservation qui va
se traduire par la lutte pour la survie
qui va se traduire par le fait de se
reproduire ça c'est notre dimension
animal mais nous n'avons pas qu'une
dimension animal nous avons aussi une
propriété qui fait de nous ce que nous
sommes qui fait de nous des êtres
humains c'est le choix le choix par
exemple de suivre les recommandations de
la nature ou de nous en écarter le choix
d'obéir à notre instinct ou de ne pas
lui obéir le choix de dire oui ou de
dire non or fondamentalement qu'est ce
que le choix il ya le choix
c'est la capacité à créer des chemins
alternatifs par rapport à l'ordre
naturel choix c'est toujours le choix de
désobéir
choix de s'écarter choix de dévier de la
trajectoire naturelle donc le choix
c'est l'origine de l'erreur de l'erreur
ou de l'errance parce que s'ils ont
choisi de s'écarter de la voix de ce qui
est bon son choisi de s'écarter du
modèle de l'ordre naturel et bien on
peut passer beaucoup de temps à errer
c'est beaucoup plus facile de suivre un
chemin quand il n'y a qu'un seul chemin
c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand les
chemins se multiplient c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui fait qu'on peut trouver un lien
entre l'intelligence et la souffrance
parfois même entre intelligence et folie
parce que l'intelligence c'est aussi la
capacité à multiplier les chemins de
penser l'intelligence va de pair avec la
complexité et donc quand il y a
plusieurs chemins quand il ya trop de
chemin
quand il ya trop de choix on est dans ce
qu'on appelle l'embarras du choix
l'embarras d'avoir à choisir parmi une
multitude de chemins hors choisir c'est
renoncer et renoncer c'est souffrir et à
partir du moment où nous désirons au
delà du nécessaire au delà de ce qui est
nécessaire à notre survie comme le font
les animaux
nous désirons des choses qui nous sont
parfois inaccessibles désirons des
choses qui parfois ne dépendent pas de
nous c'est ça le problème du choix
c'est ça le problème du choix sssa
l'origine du tourments humains la
capacité à choisir qui est en même temps
la capacité à s'écarter de la voie bonne
d'ailleurs c'est amusant parce que
bakounine l'anarchiste russe du 19e
siècle a écrit un texte dans lequel il
faisait l'éloge de satan satan qu'on a
coutume d'identifier au mal parce qu'il
disait que satan était celui qui avait
apporté à l'homme le choix ils trouvent
qu'étymologiquement dia bol ça signifie
ce qui divise excellent idée de dualité
et le choix commence avec la dualité
choix commence quand une voie
alternative apparaît vous savez c'est
l'image du petit ange sur l'épaule
droite et du petit diable sur l'épaule
gauche c'est à ce moment là que la
conscience est prise dans un dilemme
donc c'est le chemin unique qui tout à
coup se divise
et ça pour bakounine c'est la naissance
de la liberté c'est à dire la
possibilité de choisir une autre voie la
possibilité de transgresser d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'on retrouve très bien dans
le mythe d'adam et eve
parce que ce que vient apporter le
serpent dans le jardin d'éden
c'est le choix et la responsabilité qui
découlent de ce choix le choix de
transgresser la demande de dieu de ne
pas goûter le fruit défendu
et ce n'est pas pour rien que ce fruit
c'était le fruit de l'arbre de la
connaissance du bien et du mal donc ça
temps c'est à la fois le père de la
liberté le père du choix mais c'est en
même temps la source de notre malheur
parce qu'il n'ya pas de malheur quand on
suit un chemin sans se poser de
questions parce que quand on suit un
chemin sans se poser de questions il n'y
a pas de doute il n'a pas de regret il
n'y a pas d'amertume
puisqu'il n'y a pas la possibilité
d'envisager qu'un autre chemin et était
possible donc le problème de l'homme
c'est le choix et le choix conduit
l'homme à faire des erreurs des erreurs
qui le mène à la souffrance donc si on
résume un peu il ya deux idée à retenir
dans ce qu'on a dit sur la souffrance
premièrement que la souffrance c'est
d'abord le fait d'une réponse de la
réalité à notre comportement et
deuxièmement que nous avons le pouvoir
d'agir sur notre souffrance en modifiant
la représentation que nous avons des
événements donc le premier axe c'est
celui de l'adaptation de notre
comportement à la réalité
le deuxième axe c'est l'adaptation de
notre représentation des choses par
rapport à la raison universelle
ce qui veut dire que dans ce deuxième
cas c'est la raison qui nous permet de
neutraliser la souffrance c'est la
raison qui nous permet d'annuler notre
tourments et de trouver la paix
intérieure de trouver l'alignement parce
que l'alignement
c'est la mise en accord de notre pensée
avec les événements c'est la mise en
accord de notre raison avec la raison du
monde et lorsque
raison et en accord avec la raison du
monde le tourment disparaît le tourment
disparaît parce qu'alors on accepte ce
qui est on l'accepté comme une nécessité
on l'acceptent comme quelque chose que
nous n'avons pas le pouvoir de modifier
et comprendre pourquoi les choses sont
ce qu'elles sont comprendre les règles
de la nature c'est ne plus être affectés
par le monde sait ne plus subir le monde
c'est se libérer du tourment lié au fait
que les choses ne sont pas ce qu'on
voudrait qu'elle soit celle acceptée
comme une nécessité et y prendre part
activement à cordes et notre raison à la
raison universelle c'est non plus
vouloir que les choses soient comme on
le désire c'est vouloir que les choses
soient comme elles sont c'est vouloir
que les choses arrivent comme elle
arrive parce que si elle arrive comme
elle arrive c'est qu'il ya une raison
il ya toujours une raison il ya toujours
un sens et si notre un cap
était à percevoir le sens immédiatement
qui fait qu'on va plonger dans le
tourment qui fait qu'on va plonger dans
le refus et l'incompréhension il n'y a
pas plus grande source de tourments que
l'incompréhension
alors bien sûr vous allez me dire on
peut savoir qu'il ya une raison à ce qui
arrive peut être conscient que tout un
sens mais que se passe-t-il quand on
ignore cette raison que se passe-t-il
quand on sait qu'il y a une raison mais
qu'on ne la connais pas eh bien là j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est votre confiance
en la raison qui va faire la différence
et cette confiance dans la raison elle
n'est pas comme dans la religion le
fruit d'une foi aveugle elle n'est pas
le fruit d'une croyance
elle est le fruit d'un savoir que la
raison régit tout cette confiance nous
vient du fait de savoir que la raison
est dans tout et que tout est dans la
raison tout à une raisons y compris les
choses qui nous paraissent les plus
absurdes
parce que l'absurdité ce n'est rien
d'autre que le nom que l'on donne à ce
qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre
l'incompréhensible est toujours
incompréhensible pour nous
incompréhensible du point de vue notre
esprit mais rien n'échappe à la raison
tout est compréhensible
tout est compréhensible parce que tout
ce qui est à une raison d'être
rien n'arrive sans cause et même si la
cause se situe au delà de notre schéma
compréhension au delà de nos capacités
cognitives
ce n'est pas pour ça que la cause
n'existe pas c'est simplement que la
cause se situe sur un autre plan de
compréhension vous voyez si on adopte
cet angle rationaliste rationaliste au
sens littéral
c'est à dire que tout obéit à la raison
ça signifie que l'absurde est inclus
dans la raison l'absurde n'échappe pas à
la raison il échappe à nos moyens de
compréhension c'est très différent parce
que sinon ça voudrait dire que nous
sommes capables de tout comprendre
autrement dit que nous serions des êtres
commission c'est pas le cas j'ai quelque
chose qui
échappe et des choses que nous sommes
fondamentalement incapable de comprendre
mais le fait d'être incapable de les
comprendre ne doit pas occulter le fait
qu'il y a une raison il ya toujours une
raison et comprendre ça c'est devenir
capable d'accepter que les choses soient
ce qu'elles sont et non seulement
qu'elle soit ce qu'elles sont mais de
considérer comme une nécessité de le
considérer comme quelque chose qui ne
pouvait pas en être autrement
comprendre que tout est régi par la
raison c'est accepter tout ce qui est
comme une nécessité alors vous allez me
dire ok savoir que tout a une raison et
donc accepter que les choses soient ce
qu'elles sont c'est bien beau mais c'est
facile à dire merci la raison que
cynique alors oui c'est facile à dire
mais c'est facile de dire que c'est
facile à dire
c'est moins facile de l'appliquer mais
ce n'est pas impossible
c'est une question de choix on peut
choisir
roi de la complainte on peut choisir la
voie de la complaisance dans la
souffrance fait de se nourrir de ce
tournant mais on peut aussi faire le
choix de l'acceptation
on peut faire le choix de la confiance
dans la raison
qui de nous fait rien subir kiné du sens
il y as qui dépend nous et il y as qui
ne dépend pas de nous chaque fois que
nous sommes tourmentés par ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous nous négligeons ce
qui dépend de nous nous sommes un gras
envers ce qui dépend de nous nous
privons nous-mêmes de notre pouvoir de
modifier la trajectoire
lorsque nous occultons ce qui dépend de
nous on se mutile parce qu'alors on
s'ampute de notre raison qui est notre
ange gardien personnel avoir conscience
que ce qui dépend de nous dépend de nous
c'est se donner l'opportunité de bien
agir c'est se donner l'opportunité de
faire ce qui est bon pour nous les
événements qui nous arrive on ne décide
pas toujours mais pour certains on les
choisit on les provoque
on les crée et tant qu'on refusera de
voir cette capacité que nous avons à
créer donc on refusera d'assumer ce
pouvoir d'accepter ou de refuser ce qui
arrive ce pouvoir d'agir ou de ne pas
agir sur la voie du bonheur
on ne pourra s'en prendre qu'à soi le
monde n'est pas
on sable de notre malheur parce que ce
faire du monde notre maître et ce serait
faire de nous les esclaves du monde nous
sommes pas esclave
nous sommes maîtres et être maître ça
commence par en prendre conscience
prendre conscience que la raison est de
notre côté prendre conscience que la
raison ne nous trahira jamais prendre
conscience qu'en comprenant les raisons
nous devenons la raison nous devenons
semblable aux dieux et alors
d'être trouverons-nous la quiétude
trouverons-nous l'alignement la paire
intérieure
je vous remercie
[Musique]